الدقائق
[موسيقى]
Boo Boo's يرفع من مستوى القانون
هنالك
رقم
[موسيقى]
أنا
مسيرة أساكورا
أنا قسيس شحن
الشخص المسؤول عن المعبد
بيتي يشحن لأجيال ، لكنني من الجيل السابع عشر
زهرة منذ حوالي 540 سنة
لقد تم تشييده ، لكنني أفكر فيه منذ ذلك الحين.
[موسيقى]
عندما كنت صغيرا
أكره أن يقال لي أن صب المعبد لأنك تتبع
السبب في عدم إعجابي بالجبهة هو أن المعبد قديم الطراز.
شيئا ما
حار
كنت في أوائل العشرينات من عمري ، كنت أفكر في أنها كانت صلبة وسلسة.
أريد الخروج من أوتاكو بطريقة ما.
كان هناك وقت أردت فيه العمل هناك كدي جي أو عامل إضاءة.
مع استمرار العمل
إضاءة
دي جي هي وظيفة لنقل الأشياء الرائعة.
يخبر
لقد لاحظت القليل عن ذلك.
أعتقد أن العمل رائع
لذا عدت إلى الهيكل
همم
ماذا نفعل في هذا الوضع الذي يتناقص فيه عدد المصلين تدريجياً؟
لأنني مضطر
انها مجرد مثل المعلومات
ثم في المرآة
على سبيل المثال ، اتخاذ قرار بدون ميزوموتو
إضاءة حقيقية بناءً على تلك الموسيقى
مخطط الإسقاط
أكلت وجهًا حلوًا بشكل لامع
يقال أن ملك بايك هو الذي يعمل على الأكمام.
عندما بدأت هذه الخدمة التذكارية لأول مرة ، كان الناس من حولي فقط ، لكنهم يشاعون
أصبح 100 شخص في شكل Ougasa
150 شخصًا و 250 شخصًا بشكل غير متوقع
انظر صواريخ الحزب
كنت أفكر في 801 إلخ. أ
رر
[موسيقى]